Does this sound familiar? Someone plays
a threat you know will take over the
game and then surprisingly it does. How
about when the board gets so clogged up
that every creature in turn and leaving
has 12 different triggers? And how about
when Jimmy says I have an answer for
that and when the time comes Jimmy taps
two and a white for the protection.
You've changed Jimmy.
If this all sounds too familiar, your
group probably lacks interaction. And
this is understandable. Everyone wants
to do their own things, and nobody wants
to eat their vegetables. But it's easy
to forget that it's slightly more
difficult to do your own thing when
you're dead. Be the change you want to
see does not work in commander. It's
like when I came up with my 30 removal
flops deck, people play even greedier,
expecting me to deal with every threat.
So I have learned in commander if you
want to see change you need to be the
problem exacerbate it take the elephant
in the room and paint it neon pink and
today we are doing just that we're
looking at a deck that first took form
14 years ago when I was relatively new
back then the sky was blue and I was
happy until one day the mopplasm player
in my group bought a lord of extinction
that's the kind of card that has newer
players in disbelief when they first
read it. But the older players have seen
it all. Yeah. Dice to removal. Sure it
does. But once in a while there were
games where the Lord of Extinction,
sometimes with the help of a bend
wonder, just killed one opponent after
another. And when it got to me, I
learned an important lesson in magic.
When you don't have it, you don't have
it. Click subscribe for more life
lessons. But that got me thinking. If a
simple big dumb vanilla creature can
have a chance of catching people with
their pants down, what if I played a
bunch of them? And just around that time
came with Aison restored the mighty
malignance. And that made the decision
really easy. I was going junded. And you
may have already guessed why I'm
bringing this deck up now. But besides
that, to this day, the role it fills is
not only still relevant, but needed. The
sheer absurdity of dying to a simple
attacking creature is enough to make
people pick up a few more swords to
plowshares and reality shifts next time
they build a deck. The deck is led by
crush the bloodb braided partly because
seeura wasn't available back then. But
even now I find Zeura to be a little bit
too telegraphed. The fling being
displayed in the command zone versus
being hidden in your hand can lead to
very different responses from your
opponents. The idea is to play the
biggest creatures in J. Lord of
Extinction, Hamlet, Back Goliath,
Managor, Hydra, Fyrax, and Devourer,
Malignus, Realm Seekers, Yargo, and
Motani, and Motani himself, and of
course, Jumbo Cactar. Actually, the
Cactar doesn't synergize well at all
with a lot of the cards we have, but it
also works too well with some others,
and you just can't say no to cactus,
man. Meanwhile, wall of blood and fireex
processor will cost a lot of life, but
we will get that all back. I promise.
Still not big enough? we can pump even
further. Xeno Ghost is my favorite here
because it just sticks on the board and
your opponents will always have to play
around a surprise 4040 malignance on
their doorstep. And once we have a big
boy setup or two, we have the whole
package of cards putting them to work.
Draw cards, gain life. Don't worry about
sacrificing cuz none of that power and
toughness will go to waste. It all goes
to crush. And in terms of winning the
game, well, we be asking questions and
our opponents better have answers. Do
you have an answer for this 4040
trample? Oh, you do. Uh, how about for
this fling? Oh, you do. Oh, what about
the trigger from this guy who's been
stalking on the board?
We have a package to help push damage
through. Unblockable trample. And yes,
blasphemous act in this deck is an
evasion spell. And if combat fails,
here's the plan B package. This will get
damage through one way or the other.
Gerard is the strongest here, and the
sight of him usually means the game is
near finished. With so much big action,
we definitely need lots of ramp. We try
to play some that are more synergistic
with the game plan, but some of the
classics like cultivate and kodama
screech are just uh too good to pass up.
And once we have the core of the deck,
we sprinkle in some miscellaneous
utility. Removals and board wipes. With
the amount of ramp we have, we can go a
bit greedy with mana cost. And when
you're greedy, decree of paying is one
of the best cards in black. Draw
recursion. The deck requires a lot of
pieces to come together. So tutors are
extra useful, but in black and green,
there are plenty of other options if you
want to avoid the expensive game
changers. Sneak attack doesn't have the
best synergy with a lot of the creatures
in the deck, but when you go off and
draw 20 to 30 cards, it's one of the
best cards you can have in that group.
And then round things up with some more
utility lands and we are set. So there
you have it. The elephant in the room in
commander deck form. There are some
fairly expensive cards in this list, but
none are essential to the game plan and
can be replaced by some of the budget
alternatives. The deck can be a bit slow
to get going at first, but once it's
online, your opponents will be on the
edge of their seats every turn. And
after a few flings, you will start
seeing more responsible interactive play
patterns from your group, which is
perfect
because then you can pivot to the greedy
no interaction decks yourself. And that
of course was the real plan all along.
Thanks for watching.